[Music]
and blind dance news submitted by Chief
Brian a new blind date reality show has
gone viral okay you liked it there is
this reality show that is called flirty
dance is this on the Mexican channel
I feel like I could have been a better
name we could have had a better pun but
it's okay oh what's that process
remember watching that one Mexican show
and those these two people speaking
Spanish and then they're all like
dancing in front of each other
Mexican show we're typical speak Spanish
yeah I've never heard of such a thing
no cuz at first glance you don't know
it's Mexican cuz you just see like a
black guy with like a white girl and
they're dancing and talking but there's
like this screen between but then you
can see the silhouette of each other and
then at second glance you're like wait
they're speaking Mexican and then you're
like wait it says Telemundo on and a
Chan that lower-right that's we're weird
channel 34 and ours I this is
interesting
so I think this is what the talk about
yep you're right exactly this is the
trailer for a new reality show I will
show it to you now so cute so cute the
holiday season witness a blind date like
no other
oh wow yeah Big John this is way better
than that Mexican show us off we're two
strangers
me for the first time Jenna Dewan host
flirty dancing how come by a lot of
bands if they're just so each person
they have a teacher to teach each person
their part and then they meet up and
they do it yeah so cool
we went viral recently so it says I have
been introduced to hashtag flirty
dancing a blind date show where two
people learning dance separately and
then must perform it upon meeting each
other and now I'm ruined so this show
actually came from the UK was on channel
4 but then now they're bringing it to
the US and now it's on Fox 4 for
American middle-aged white ladies who
drink wine why why that ruin was what
happened meaning like the emotion yeah
it's not for you it's not for you piss
on tip-toe or in order to have like oh
could like to have a good dance with
someone else like you guys have to have
chemistry to like look really good if
you like learn the choreography the
dudes like ugly you're like you don't
want to touch them really good that'd be
so funny so my question is people yeah
these people they're gonna dance for the
first time together right yeah no
meeting for the first meet and dance for
the first time is it also it's a real
date for the first yeah well I mean
touching for the first time I'm gonna
show you guys this clip that so remember
how I showed you that that sweet it came
with the video I will show you that
video am I gonna need tissues am I gonna
cry I don't think so you know me cry
think about your own childhood did your
about my coughs childhood I cried not my
own yeah that's pretty good okay he
doesn't have a I like his shirt all
right here we go
[Music]
first time meeting it's so you know I
don't like this kind of stuff he's like
damn boy you could dance how cute
they're so like into it I love it
want to sing me
how do you find all these people that
could dance yeah Toby audition hmm I get
goosebumps a lot of you what I can't
dance that's true they're really
goodness yeah they can move
I'm gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you later
homie that's what's going on in their
minds right now these whisper that he's
like Oh can't wait till I stick my dick
in you you want to be rare on you homie
we're gonna 77 that way you say to a
girl you're on a date it's not a brain
all right take my dick out usually first
any wiggle it around
that's so cute laughter that's pretty
beautiful emotional dude oh I love it
what happened to you Bart I'm feeling
these feelings man are you imagining
tyka no problem with this being a blind
date though it's what is that gonna
happen though because they're on TV so
they're just gonna go it's like a grand
entrance and it's like wait can I get a
new partner like to lift your partner
but you can lift your port because
they're so bad that's good
Oh how do you know or you could just be
very weak to like the scrawny is dude in
the world yes so some reactions to this
is this is the most romantic thing I
love it and where can i watch this show
another one said if I gotta do this to
get a man I'm I'm unsubscribe from how
many people show the by dates a bit like
really oh yeah are you Kevin oh you are
yeah I gotta go
my friends following me my stove on
sorry buddy my friends in a horrible
accident that would be my show we make
sure that people are incompatible
[ __ ] oh that is so good you watch the
[ __ ] out of it that's like the best part
of American Idol it's like the shitty
people right set it up so then it's not
great oh that's super neo-nazi maximum
conflict will hold my neo-nazi and a Jew
yep but they're both good at dancing
maybe they can make it work
maybe they'll connect through the dance
right
maybe yeah find peace through the day
I'm trying on some Jewish German tunes
they condensed to me yeah let me see so
another one says would rather be alone
for the rest of my [ __ ] life there's
a period after each word well use you
can't dance
yeah probably so a lot of people don't
like it blind dates are just already so
insanely like scary and intimidating Hey
you have to do this on a blind date it's
like [ __ ] scary to you it's so corny I
couldn't take it serious so another one
thank you I was prepared to cringe
because I assumed this concept was a
joke but now i'm sobbing as they eat
helping you chips and I rub my eyes and
I won't blame but it's okay because this
tweet was the last thing I saw okay calm
down Barbara Jesus Christ man another
one says the first couple that does this
dance at their wedding after meeting on
this show will be the death of me
oh don't be cute they realize there's a
lot of hopeless romantics out there huh
and they're all middle-aged women
this one though says I am so utterly
married I cringe left and rolled my eyes
through this whole thing whoa
imagine being there and being your
personality congratulations you're not
married yeah deal with mortgage you
[ __ ] I'm so married but I thought so
nice but heavier at Acadia yeah only
identity of course it's that fun on the
first damn
I'm married oh that's all you got going
for you married and all the complaints
of being married what does he think
about blind dates what do people why are
people so romanticized blind dates
maybe that rush of passion for just a
sudden reaction of I like you you like
me I think it's the destiny angle I
think people people crave destiny one
truth the perfect love story and so they
look for that beginning and something
that seems like a long shot
yeah or desperation I don't want to
[ __ ] look anymore yeah I'm so picky
like would you know who to set me up
with I would which I mean yeah I just
don't know anyone that would a fat
person Prince oh okay
the hairier the I don't want to whack
them and you could pop their pimples
Oh see there we go elbow the other day
that popped it and I recorded it and I
said that the Julia look you get
something on your elbow I don't know so
weird
I said that Julian Julia's like oh my
God thank you for this what do you say
you're hard to set up why why are you
hard to set up a piggy okay yeah I'm
super picky what are your pet peeves
well my [ __ ] nose you know [ __ ] no oh
[ __ ] no would be the size of a nostril
do you know what you want or is it you
are you picky because you don't know
what you want I know what I want that's
the reason why I'm so picky because I
know exactly
do tell what the [ __ ] I'm very like it's
weird it's hard to put into words I like
I'm tall okay handsome right absolute I
don't like to buff because that scares
the [ __ ] out of me
I've seen you date guys that aren't tall
like they're just regular height oh
those are just space fillers mm you're
talking about like your marriage
material not your side [ __ ] funny
like I love funny guys do you like funny
guys that are tall and handsome so fun
picture and Tom Green Tom pretty yes be
attractive
yeah what about nineties Tom Green
nineties Tom he was so weird luck just
checking out these are kinda gauge it
what do you consider tall uh if I'm
wearing heels and I'm still shorter than
you know that's fine so I like out like
510 it up okay cuz that we're like
foreign just pretty average for Western
type five six mm-hmm well you make it
pretty easy alright gotta be six foot or
whatever six million dollars Jesus like
I want a six foot Cambodian man you know
what that's gonna be
Vietnamese man a six foot North Korean
that's no that's a you know that's when
I die lonely yeah yeah see must have
tattoos no we're all going physical here
what about the other attributes no she
did say like funny humor dark humor dark
you gark dark humorous any like a little
bit of trauma spur get on top because
that makes things fun yeah a lot of that
funeral humor dude last time I was
playing junk stunts stupid what the guy
and it was a this the card said would
take advantage of a child's make-a-wish
Foundation and we both say I mean the
kid's gonna die anyways so that's out of
humor crazy goat [ __ ] and what a
wonderful foundation it is by the way
yeah see if they're connecting to you or
not
dude I had a cousin who did make-a-wish
no joke and she got to meet jewel the
seeing of jewel and then she had her
peak or like last year no no this is
like just like early 2000s Joe and she
was popular yeah and so and then we all
went to SeaWorld
I guess you wanted to go there let's do
it this is a very strange combination of
things but then she never died which I
thought was coming she came the system
right so I think that she got better and
they weren't necessarily well that was
kind of I thought that that was kind of
I was always like hey how's cousin
whatever doing cuz I only met her one
have to give back a refund if you
actually survived I think you should
like if only if you're terminally ill
that's more the deal isn't it that's
kind of [ __ ] up if you don't die right
I'm just saying make-a-wish should send
people to to their houses and just to
chickens
I think there's a lot of so they should
investigate yeah
[Music]
[Music]